Okay Michael, so we've gone on a journey of discovery. [LAUGH] Through
unsupervised learning, and so my question to you is, what have we learned?
>> I think we learned a little bit about ourselves.
>> And a little bit about America.
So what A's have we learned today, Michael?
>> So there was PCA.
>> Mm-hmm.
>> ICA.
>> LDA.
>>
Mm-hmm. RCA and USA.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
USA, we're number one! Whoo!
>> [LAUGH]
>> Okay, we're just going to erase that little bit. [LAUGH]
>> Okay, yeah, okay, so we learned about a lot of A's today.
>> Uh-huh.
>> Which is the same grade that all our students
are going to get, I am sure. That would be great.
>> Or
that's if they're truly independent. If they aren't independent, then the
central limit theorem says, there will be a normal distribution across grades.
>> Mm-mmm.
>> Ring that bell curve.
>> Aw, yeah, baby. Okay. So we learned about PCA,
ICA, LDA and RCA. What else did we learn about?
>> Well, I think that was it. But we talked about specifically.
we, we talked in detail about the relationships between some of these.
>> Mm-hm.
>> In particular, these are all examples of
feature transformation.
>> That's right. Okay, so we found out about the relationships
between different transformation analysis. Oh,
here's something we learned. We learned
that the A doesn't just stand for analysis. In the algorithms,
but it actually does stand for the analysis of the data.
>> Because that's unsupervised learning.
>> That's right. And that in particular I
gave some examples where ICA tells you what the
underlying structure of the data is. You can use it to find structure.
So that, for example, the independent components of natural scenes are edges.
So it's interesting, because I feel like the other time that you
emphasized structure was when you were talking about, mimic which was a
piece of work that you did when you were a graduate student.
>> Yep
>> One would almost want to guess that maybe
you worked on ICA when you were a graduate student.
>> I actually did. My very first paper
as a young graduate student was on mimic and my very last paper
as a young graduate student. My
actual dissertation, was on independent components analysis.
>> I had that sense from the number of strong
points you felt the need to make [LAUGH] about ICA.
>> Well listen man, really, structure runs my life.
As you know, everything about my life is well-structured.
>> Yeah, sure.
>> [LAUGH] Okay, did we learn anything else?
>> So, yeah, so I mean I feel like we spent a lot of time talking about
so P, ICA is a more probabilistic kind of modeling, method
and PCA is a more I want to say linear algebraic, modeling model.
>> That's a really good point Michael. So, we didn't say it explicitly this
way, but actually, even in our own work it often comes up that sometimes,
you want to think about, information theory. You
want to think about probability. And sometimes, you
really just want to think about linear algebra. And you could see PCA as being
really about linear algebra. And sometimes only
coincidentally being about probability. Where as ICA
is all about probability and information theory,
and only coincidentally ever about linear algebra.
>> Yeah, that's helpful. That does seem to be a fundamental
split in a lot of work that happens in machine learning.
>> Yeah and it, and it makes some sense. I mean, we, we
know what the right answer is in probability, but we know what the
right answer is in linear algebra. And I guess it's, it's often the
case Michael, would you agree that. That the linear algebra approach is often
easier to think about, or easier to do in
practice and sometimes, it can be interpreted as if
it's probability. And that typically breaks down on the
edge cases, but you know, you can kind of
work around it for sort of common cases. Yeah,
that, that the linear algebra algorithms are often cheaper
to implement, cheaper to execute less prone to local
minima issues. There's sort of a well defined answer
that they're, that they're finding. But it's often not quite the
answer that you want, and the probability methods give you the
answer that you want, but can be very hard to find.
Right. And in fact you can see that in ICA and PCA,
in that PCA is very well understood. There are lots of
fast algorithms for it. And you know that the principle components
always exist. Interestingly, we didn't talk about this but by contrast,
ICA with its more information, theoretic and probabilistic roots, has a very
specific model. And it isn't always the case
that that model fits, and so in fact, sometimes
you can't find independent components. [INAUDIBLE] Because they don't
actually exist, except in the most trivial sense. So
it's both more expensive, because of the way
you end up searching the space. And it doesn't
always produce an answer. But when it does produce
an answer, it tends to produce very satisfying ones.
>> Well, I think that's a good place to stop, in the
sense that I wanted to know just one more interesting fact about ICA.
And now that I've got that, I feel
fully satisfied. Well, there's another fact I can
tell you which is that it's the only
one of these algorithms that start with a vowel.
>> And now I'm more than satisfied.
>> It is always my goal to leave you more than satisifed.
>> [LAUGH]. Alright, then!
>> OK. Well I think we are done
with this entire sub lesson mini course thingy.
>> About unsupervised learning.
Well that, well that's great!
>> What does that, what does that leave us to do? Doesn't lead us to do
anything, at least not with this particular, mini-course.
I think actually the description we had here, what
we've learned for this particular, lesson actually applies,
even going backwards to some of our other
lessons. And what we're going to get to do
next is, decision problems and reinforcement learning. Ooo, exciting.
>> It is exciting.
>> But I think first people probably have some
homeworky stuff to do, projects to do in the context of this minicourse.
>> Yes, and probably an exam of some sort.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Good luck to everyone on that.
>> Yes, we're absolutely sure you'll do fine.
Be sure to go over these lessons and be
sure to read all of the material, because there's
a lot of detail in the material that wouldn't
make a lot of sense for us to cover in this format. But do give it a
read, come back, look at the stuff that we've
talked about, it should help you understand the intuition
behind whats really happening there. Excellent. Well this
is great, thanks, thanks Charles, i learned a lot,
>> I did too. Bye Michael i will hear from you soon. Alright, awesome.
>> Bye.